il ya un an 20 on a d'un petit foyer
chez moi là bas viens on s'est cotisé en
acheter platine et à des messages
et puis ben comment dire les soirs dans
s'entraîner c'est pas trop difficile
j'ai pas trop trop difficile
donc si j'ai bien compris et vous aussi
pour être disque-jockey il suffit de
savoir pousser sur les boutons
dj le mot magique qui fait rêver les
jeunes générations
dj l'homme miracle capable de vous
donner des fourmis dans les jambes le
samedi soir points communs chez tous les
disc-jockeys la passion elle les dévore
généralement dès leur plus jeune âge
[Musique]
j'adorais la musique j'étais chercher
toujours les nouveautés dans les disques
et tous les magasins j'ai un petit somme
au budget ni medel des soirées entre
copains et tous ont fait sans dire
pourquoi pour être plus branché que le
copain on achète les derniers disques
qui sortent
oui pour son plaisir personnel se faire
plaisir après tout c'est facile mais
procurer du plaisir aux danseurs sur la
piste c'est une autre affaire celui qui
a fait durant dix ans les beaux jours de
la salle wagram le plus grand parc et
pâle de paris n'hésite pas à rapprocher
le dj du musicien de bal
alors finalement vidéo tard le musicien
de bal a été un petit peu remplacé par
le disc jockey
oui mais le principe doit rester le même
les musiciens de bal qui étaient les
prolétaires de la vie artistique était
cependant des gens fabuleux parce qu'ils
avaient un instinct extraordinaire il
pouvait prévoir à la seconde près
qu'elle allait être l'ambiance on ne
programme pas on pouvait dire à tel
moment là ça va chauffer là il faut
décompresser
car dans la musique il faut qu'il y ait
une respiration dans une soirée c'est
comme dans la vie de tous les jours et
le disc jockey qui réussissent et celui
qui à cette psychologie
bien que la machine soit plus importante
mais la machine douanes ne doit être
qu'un accessoire
ce qui compte c'est le rapport qui doit
y avoir entre celui qui commande la
machine et le public est ce que ça veut
dire que le disque-jockey doit aussi
être un peu musicien obligatoirement ce
doit être une balle de ping pong
la musique est une soirée comme une
pièce de théâtre il doit y avoir un
rebondissement sans aller donc on doit
connaître les impôts on doit connaître
les tonalités et sans arrêt changé et
surprendre l'oreille du danseur pour
l'inciter à chaque fois rentrés dans
votre
le disc-jockey a fait son apparition il
ya une quinzaine d'années pour affirmer
le rôle de boîte de nuit comme lieu
privilégié de divertissement à l'époque
il s'agissait surtout de gagner un peu
d'argent de poche en s'amusant
aujourd'hui on peut parler d'une vraie
profession les dj sont des salariés
bénéficiant d'une couverture sociale
normale
ils ont même un championnat de france
pour se mesurer une compétition qui
permet de les rendre plus crédible je
crois ça va leur faire prendre le métier
de disc jockey au sérieux je crois que
c'est ce qui m'a encore un peu dans
cette profession disque-jockey connu
qu'est ce que je fais et gagne pas et 10
pour effort vraiment savez une
profession et quelques années sur un
métier qui sera reconnue de tous
importants je pense pour ces jeunes
c'est à limoges les gens n'ont pas cette
satisfaction je suis dans la france
entière il ya plein d'endroits où on a
besoin de se battre pour ce métier là l
image en particulier donc cela fait voir
qu'il existe une profession très
sérieuse en limousin on dénombre 60 de
discothèque est légèrement plus de disc
jockey ils sont payés soit à la soirée
entre 300 ans pour les débutants et 1500
francs pour les stars soit au mois entre
5000 et treize mille francs en moyenne
un bon dj gagne huit mille francs
mensuels avec ses vrais des journées de
travail complètement décalé moi je 15h
quoi de l'après midi je viens ici a dit
ce quota et faire quelques trucs qui à
faire toujours la routine un petit peu
de ménage à voir les disques que j'ai
reçues et tout est ensuite on écoule
jusqu'à 10 heures aux rondeurs et après
on attaque calme dans la soirée sur le
coup d'une heure du matin on se défonce
jusqu'à 4 5 heures
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
chants du présent et je les ai ouvert
mon fils
particules et beaubien milliards
mauvais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
si on parle déjà d'une profession à part
entière celle ci a toutefois bien du mal
à se définir officiellement le dj a
déclaré aux ursaff comme animateur mais
ceux qui ont participé aux derniers
championnats de france ont réalisé un
véritable show scénique
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est bien un petit peu dans la
même
qui est devenue un mode qui vont samedi
ce jeu cassés jet faire un show d'hier
avec une idée un terme etc
et puis il faut savoir je prends à
chanter enfin le dise ok n'est plus là
seulement pour passer des disques et
puis dire trois mois je crois que ça
devient un artiste vous sentez oui ce
sont les chanteurs danseurs musiciens
les meilleurs dj le sont sûrement
reste que dans la plupart des
discothèques province le dise propre et
s'occupe essentiellement de ses platines
et puis dj ne rime pas forcément avec
boîte de nuit
depuis dix ans les discos mobiles
sillonnent nos campagnes le principe est
simple sur un plancher de valve on
fabrique de toutes pièces une
discothèque grandeur nature
[Musique]
est ce que ce n'est pas pénible pour
vous que pour le surtout pour le
disque-jockey d'avoir à monter et à
démonter dans la nuit il maintient que
le montage ça va c'est encore
relativement agréable et souvent ce qui
se passe mal c'est le démontage à 3
heures du matin quand on a une soirée
assez fatigantes le dj des fois à du mal
enfin il a sa place dans l'équipe et la
tient jusqu'au bout patty bien moins
familiers aux dj à vivre ses nuits à
cent à l'heure le disc jockey ne tient
pas la piste très longtemps passé la
trentaine il se sent hors du coup et
dérape parfois du sillon musicale en
vogue
la carrière du dj n'excédant guère
quinze années reste à savoir ce qui
vient derrière au défaut du budget
actuel c'est la puissance 80% des dj ne
savent pas maîtriser une console freeze
à sion et abuse des watts et je pense
que pour cela il faudrait les les former
il faudrait réformer parce que la
plupart donc jamais suffi de formation
et ça c'est déplorable
justement vous avez un projet sur
l'image d'un gros projet sur l'image
n'est en train de construire une école
de disc jockey avec la participation de
fait l'organisation l'organisateur du
championnat de france des jockeys où on
formera des disc-jockeys dans une salle
de spectacle on le fera travailler avec
un public ce qui permettra aux patrons
discothèque tous les départements de
france de venir les voir y voir mais
aussi les embaucher et même acheter le
matériel qu'ils utilisent autant dire
que le futur établissement limougeaud
devrait attirer pas mal de propriétaires
de night club
dj le rêve de gosse reste difficile à
réaliser talent psychologie ténacité
forces morales et physiques sont
indispensables mais au fil des ans ces
mordus du rythme s'impose comme de vrais
professionnels
avec encore une marge de qualité à
atteindre marges qui devraient toutefois
se réduire si cette profession naissante
parvient à se structurer et à former
correctement ceux qui l'ont adopté
[Musique]